our next award is very special it honors
a 50-year career in our in our industry
and to do the honors we have a special
presenter so while i get back to go
there and take a little breather would
you please welcome the distinguished
actor and director dennis hopper
what a great job she's doing such a
difficult one
well you know
to give this award tonight is probably
the greatest honor i've ever had
bestowed on me when i
when i opened the letter that asked me
to give this award i just uh i thought
boy if you just live long enough you
know
in the winter of
1946
after a tour in the navy
joe lombardi moved to southern
california from his home in new jersey
he got a job of building houses out in
the valley
where he was approached and asked if he
could
build a circular staircase for a motion
picture production
and the rest is
film history
joe's first special effects work was for
the three stooges at columbia pictures
now uh while joe's always been noted for
his concerns about safety on the set
i'm pretty sure it's just a rumor that
when moe went like this
that it was joe who told larry to do
this you know
anyway
joe went on to work on set construction
and sequentially special effects on the
i love lucy show which eventually led to
long-term relationships with danny
thomas and red skelton
it was lucy who gave joe the name for
his newly founded company in 1960 when
she remarked that his talent was
unlimited thus special effects unlimited
was born
over the years joe has supervised
special effects on a list of films as
long as your arm
it's an incredible uh it's incredible
work
and it's been an incredible career
which i'm happy to report is still going
very strong
uh this uh this award of con
commendation reads to joe lombardi
in celebration of 50 years in the motion
picture industry
his knowledge and leadership in the
field of pyrotechnics and special
effects along with his uncompromising
promotion of safety on the set have
established the standard for today's
special effects technicians
it's a pleasure and a great honor to
present this award to the joe lombardi
i want to thank dennis especially dennis
and i have been involved in apocalypse
now super mario brothers
and a few specialties that he had on his
own
over there
this is a very special moment for me and
i feel fortunate to be here tonight
looking back at my career it looks like
years have gone by too quickly
i think it's because i love this
business
and it provided with me and my family
and i thank god that i have a great
career and helped
make a lot of shows traveled all over
the world and met a lot of people
there are some special people who
deserve my thanks
lucille ball who gave me a break in the
business and who encouraged me to pursue
special effects
desi arnaz one of the smartest producers
ever
danny thomas a hell of an actor a
humanitarian
and a generous friend and the greatest
comedian red skelton
directors john irving francis coppola
and john milius for believing in me and
let me do things i like to make their
films exciting i also want to thank
my close friend don rogers as well as
kevin pike ray feeney pete clark and my
partner gabe develop
who have had a role in this award last
but not least i want to thank my
daughter susan who is here tonight along
with my son paul whose accomplishment
and special effects have made me very
very proud i wish her mother were alive
to share this with me
in closing i want to thank the academy
and the scientific award for this
special award you have really made my
day thank you
you